Cyrus doesn't want to say this but on
her TV show and just like that she plays
a podcast host and she models herself
after me I do I do no you don't know
Sex in the City yes yes Sex and the City
by the way you're very unprofessional
you're having sex in the first episode
with your producer which I have done as
well I have sex with Gary regularly
he's sexual as hell but but that is
inappropriate behavior right to have sex
with your boss Miranda would think so
you give up the power
but then she then they broke it off then
she broke it off am I but was that a
spoiler no I've heard the spoiler is
that you're going to be with that uh
what's that that odd dude's name John
Corbin John Corbett John Corbin is
coming back yeah yeah John Corbett's
coming back and there'll be sex scenes
oh your tongue is out I guess that means
yes I mean yeah it's an affectionate
relationship yeah yeah
they're very tactile they're very
physical those two
and of course we should mention even
though uh you know Kim Cattrall will be
making it Academy yeah
[Music]
the show this Show's terrific if you
want my opinion I'm happy for Kim and
I'm happy for you that you'll be on it
but I know I'm excited Sarah Jessica
Parker and just like that now this is on
Max you know they changed the name it's
no longer HBO Max no it's not it's not
HBO anymore are you happy about that are
you glad that it's now on Max I mean
what is exciting now there's going to be
a new episode uh a new episode premiere
every Thursday that's right like
old-fashioned TV like old-fashioned
television and then they'll just like
accumulate like scar tissue yes it's
very exciting
hello